ce qui est sûr ce qui se passe
actuellement à lui disais c'est ce qui
s'est passé cet après midi cette
rencontre entre le président de la
république et les partenaires sociaux
pour voir comment faire face
comment éviter la casse sociale
après avec la violente crise économique
que nous connaissons et que nous allons
connaître puisque la récession qui
s'annonce et de 11% bien plus que les 8
% qu'on craignait déjà un autre chiffre
inquiète ce sont des les prévisions du
chômage puisque selon les chiffres mêmes
et les annonces même de la ministre du
travail mme muriel pénicaud
il devrait dépasser les 10% re dépassé
la barre des 10% cette année et je
souligne à ce sujet que la ministre du
travail est à l'origine d'un dispositif
voté il ya une semaine dans la nuit du
28 au 29 mai et un indice positif
concerne les entreprises qui vont être
concernés par le chômage partiel de
longue durée si on peut dire est qu'ils
pourront je cite pas raccord avec les
organisations syndicales diminuer le
temps de travail est pratiqué une
modération salariale à condition de
maintenir intégralement l'emploi la
modération salariale c'est le mot poli
pour dire qu'on va pas augmenter les
tarifs les salaires alors dans ces
conditions
ryanair va plus loin et soulève
l'indignation puisque la compagnie
propose elle une réduction de 20 % de
salaire de certains de ses cadres du 10%
de ses hôtesses et stewards contre le
maintien intégral des emplois en france
on n'en est pas là mais on n'en est pas
loin
à entendre en tout cas le ministre de
l'action et des comptes publics
gérald darmanin de manière générale on
voit bien que les salaires sont assez
bas pour une partie de la classe
ouvrière pour reprendre un mot populaire
et que moi je pense pas qu'il faille par
ailleurs les augmenter de façon
généralisée saturé de l'emploi en
revanche il faut augmenter le pouvoir
d'achat de nos concitoyens en balles et
a fait sa part il a supprimé la taxe
d'habitation il a supprimé des
cotisations c'est augmenter le salaire
il à baisser l'impôt sur le revenu et
par ailleurs c'est aux entreprises
désormais de faire la leur dans un
contexte économique très difficile j'ai
eu l'occasion de dire que pour moi la
grande idée de la participation de
l'actionnariat salarié de
l'intéressement et
une façon d'augmenter le pouvoir d'achat
sans toucher aux salaires
en revanche l élu communiste ian brossât
lui jugent tous ces procédés inutile sa
démonstration
les entreprises qui demandent à signer
ces fameux accords de performance
collective ce ne sont pas des pme ce
sont des grosses boîtes et on l'a
d'ailleurs avec vous et on l'a
d'ailleurs vu par le passé
michelin michelin la roche sur yon c'est
plus de 600 salariés en 2016 les
salariés acceptent de faire des
sacrifices
aujourd'hui le site ferme jeu qu'ils
veulent et où vous qu'il voulait en
finir avec le salariat est ce que c'est
le est ce que c'est le moment
et quid de cette idée donc défendu il ya
quelques jours maintenant une dizaine de
jours par le ministre de l'action des
comptes publics on a entendu jane harman
1 sur la participation dans cet ouvrage
est jeune et petit le sujet c'était
c'était on expliquait que la cgt en de
fortis dans la convention damien disait
surtout pas le salarié surtout pas le
salarié alors qu'aujourd'hui ils n'ont
plus que ce mot pas à travers la bouche
c'est juste la petite 1,6
non mais dans cet ouvrage surtout on
parlait de quelque chose qu'on a oublié
pendant cette crise et le travail
indépendant ses désirs le travail
indépendant va se développer de plus en
plus parce que la société elle craque
comme ça des interstices dans l'est dans
l'émission et ces gens là sont assez mal
soit assez mal protégé je crois qu'on
est tous d'accord pour vanter les
mérites de notre modèle social quel que
soit notre vision de l'économie
il faut protéger les indépendants et
dans cette crise si les salariés seront
très protégée et vous avez vu qu'un élu
communiste est quand même capable de
nous expliquer qu'on vit dans une des
statures alors qu'on a mis 13 millions
de personnes au chômage partiel c'est
quand même un truc de dingue
s'il passait son bac d'économie il y
aurait deux et ils redoublerait sa
terminale c'est pas bon je suis un peu
je suis un peu agacé mais au-delà de ça
et de dias qui a énormément de gens qui
ne sont absolument pas protégé où ils
vont encaisser une petite indemnité de
1500 euros pour payer toutes leurs
activités et ses et ces gens là
eh bien c'est la base d'un travail
monocellulaires qui est extrêmement
important qui se développe de plus en
plus et vous le savez dans les médias il
ya énormément de gens qui ont ce type de
deux statues mais ailleurs aussi donc ça
c'est très important ce qui va se passer
à l'elysée eh bien on en a parlé à
cordes de performance collective je
crois que c'est la moindre des choses
aujourd'hui se dire l'état a plutôt bien
réagi en mettant tout le monde sous
perfusion et le terme n'est pas galvaudé
dans ma bouche
mais derrière il faut que les
entreprises elles refassent leur travail
et qu'elles soient capables de recréer
de la valeur donc quand on sait que le
premier poste d'investissement dans une
entreprise c'est ses ressources humaines
et donc les salaires et bien que tous
ensemble on se dise si pendant un an
ça sera difficile plutôt que de mourir
et de laisser prendre des parts de
marché aux américains ou à tout un tas
de 2,2 d'entreprises étrangères et bien
il faut qu'on soit capable tous ensemble
de dire si on doit faire des efforts
faisons le et on rattrapera plus tard et
ce point là est très important il faut
sortir des discours de classe qui
consiste à opposer l'actionnaire
entreprises et les salariés de l'autre
côté tout le monde est dans le même
bateau
1 encore une fois je crois que c'est ce
qu'il faut essayer de vendée et roux de
bézieux était plutôt bien ce matin à la
radio en dix ans ryanair la manière dont
ils le disent de manière abrupte très
autoritaire à la manière anglo saxon bon
c'est pas notre façon de faire donc on
n'ose pas la façon de faire mais le
message qui est de dire on doit tous
faire des efforts pour que l'entreprise
ne meurt pas parce que on n'a jamais
connu ça depuis 1929
eh bien je pense que communistes ou pas
on devrait tous se mettent autour de la
table pour dire c'était important qu'on
fasse des efforts alors alors al'inverse
richard est ce que la meilleure solution
c'est pas de se dire c'est créer des
richesses c'est ça qui prévalent
l'emploi ouais je sais vaches et pas
trop d'accord bien évidemment avec le
discours de jacky je considère qu
effectivement dans cette crise les
indépendants n'ont pas été assez protégé
mais je trouve que dans le discours il
ya une opposition entre les les
indépendants et les salariés que je ne
trouve pas forcément très constructive à
terme je pense qu'il faut plutôt
améliorer le statut aujourd'hui des
indépendants et notamment leur ai
clairement élèves plutôt que d'aller
taper sur sur les salariés moi je suis
je trouve qu'on est passé très vite d'un
discours à un autre c'est à dire que
j'ai beaucoup entendu pendant la crise
le moment de crise due au vide et où on
était confiant
et le fait qu'il allait falloir revoir
certains salaires notamment de tous ceux
qui étaient dans en première ligne que
ce soit les éboueurs soit les caissières
que ce soit certaines infirmières des
auxiliaires de vie et on a dit qu' il
fallait qu'à l'issue de cette crise on
puisse revoir une partie de de ses
salaires qui était en gros beaucoup trop
bas et qu'il n'avait pas pouvoir rester
on a même évoqué le fait qu'il fallait
peut-être revoir l'échelle des salaires
à l'aune de leur utilité sociale c'est à
dire qu'en fait on avait peut-être comme
ça en frontline des gens qui étaient
peut-être trop mal payé pas suffisamment
reconnus et que en gros on devait revoir
l'échelle des salaires j'ai vu aussi que
les soignants il fallait revoir leurs
salaires à des revaloriser parce que
effectivement il n'était pas si on les
comparait à la fois ce qui se passe en
europe mais aussi au travail qui est
d'aileurs pas rémunérés à leur juste
alors juste l'enregistrent tâche donc
j'ai envie de dire qu'ils payent la
crise qui paye les efforts je crois que
tout français c'est qu'ils doivent à un
moment donné qu'il va être amené à faire
des efforts personne n'est dupe et on
sait qu on sait qu'il ya eu un trou vert
vincent on le sait mais néanmoins je
trouve qu'on est passé un peu trop vite
de il faut revaloriser les salaires il
faut revoir l'échelle de l'utiliser
social pour construire les salaires a
aujourd'hui la solution inverse qui est
on va baisser les salaires pour
maintenir l'emploi vous imaginez à une
époque la gauche avait osé dire il faut
partager le temps de travail pour
maintenir l'emploi et maintenant l'année
à il faut baisser les salaires pour
maintenir l'emploi
je ne sais pas si c'est le monde d'après
mais ça ne présage pas quelque chose qui
est pertinent je pense qu'il faut
regarder ça autrement que simplement par
ce type de solutions et si on a su
protéger avant il faudra accompagner la
sortie quand même si je ne prône is
baisser les salaires ça va être bon pour
relancer la consommation ça kriss kross
nous disions baisse mon salaire je mets
dirais je me mets direct en grève et
j'appelle les gilet jaune
si vous recherchez un chris kraus je me
mets en direct en grève j'appelle les
gilet jaune à occuper l'usiné
et alors au niveau des solutions le land
starter nous dit en france il faut
relancer les petites entreprises et
punir là que la concurrence déloyale et
roland estime que tout ça couvait entre
guillemets lakovic 19
il a juste révélé alexandre le medef
suggère aujourd'hui un allègement à un
allègement de charges contre la
formation d'après d'apprentis finalement
est-ce que ça c'est pas l'une des
meilleures pistes c'est oui
effectivement c'est une piste qui me
paraît intéressante pour rebondir sur ce
qui a été dit deux choses moches ou
aussi il est très attaché ou au travail
indépendant
d'ailleurs on va voir que dans 7 kg si
le sauver l'économie réelle en réalité
il ya une économie virtuelle qui va
résister avec les startups connecter la
grande distribution mondialisée la
finance globalisée également elle
plongera va être de sauver les artisans
les commerçants les entrepreneurs qui
sont le coeur
effectivement du travail en france est
une source d'emplois très grande même si
nos politiques ont trop tendance à
regarder les indicateurs
macroéconomiques et partent au ski et le
micro mais moi non plus je ne poserai
pas le salariat ou aux indépendants je
crois que pour que les indépendants
travail il faut que les gens soient
également bien payés et qu'ils puissent
et qu'ils puissent consommer donc je
crois qu'il faut continuer mouahaha
stimuler l'activité surtout il faut de
la justice c'est à dire que le problème
en france c'est que le travail ne paie
pas donc on va envoyer le signal aux
gens qui bossent leur dire votre salaire
va être diminué c'est un mauvais signal
et c'était la raison pour laquelle les
gilets jaunes sont sources et se sont
soulevés donc je crois qu'effectivement
la solution est plus dans la stimulation
de l'emploi plus peut-être à couper
justement certaines dépenses sociales
qui n'incite pas certains individus à
travailler là il ya des effectivement
peut-être des économies à faire on a vu
aussi dans le domaine de l'hôpital une
bureaucratie un peu folle mais pas du
tout sûr sur les salaires mais je crois
qu'on comptera d'ailleurs en 2008 les
états mais plutôt bien réagi au début en
stimulant l'activité en mettant en place
des dispositifs de relance keynésienne
et quelque temps après ils ont mis en
place l'austérité et on voit bien que la
zone euro
par rapport à d'autres pays depuis
maintenant près de près d'une décennie
donc nous reproduisons pas cette erreur
là maintenant les dispositifs d'inde
essayons pour l'avenir de réfléchir à
comment diminuer les dépenses sociales
et en même temps mettre en place des
dispositifs de protection pour soutenir
l'investissement productif pour soutenir
les indépendants et c'est comme ça qu'on
s'en sert tiers s'en sortir à si on
revient maintenant à l'austérité
on est parti pour des décennies de
récession anne charlène dans tous ces
débats quand même sous jacent on se dit
que quelque part c'est toujours un peu
le privé qui payent qui est la variable
d'ajustement et les salariés du privé
c'est malheureusement un peu la loi un
qui veut ça c'est à dire que bon il ya
cette fameuse sécurité de l'emploi
public qui fait qu'on a le sentiment
qu'il ya une espèce de bulle dans la
république qui serait cette partie de la
vie économique
néanmoins je crois que c'est quand même
loin d'être le cas aussi puisque bourse
et la fonction publique à la papa a
aujourd'hui beaucoup vécu il ya beaucoup
de contractuels qui sont dans des
situations de précarité tout à fait
identique a eu malheureusement bien
préoccupante à celles du privé
moi ce sur quoi je voulais revenir c'est
le sait le caractère un peu je crois que
geoffroy roux de bézieux un peu cow boy
delà de la déclaration qu'on nous a fait
c'est à dire cette espèce de huy de
chantage affectif au salariat ou au
licenciement
néanmoins il faut rappeler quand même
que c'est presque le principe du
licenciement économique c'est-à-dire
qu'il faut l'accord du salarié pour une
baisse de salaire avant de lui faire
comprendre que de toute façon si on n'a
pas son accord
on lancera une conseillère de
licenciement économique la seule vérité
c'est que ryanair n'est pas autant au
fond du gouffre qu'elle pourrait le
prétendre par rapport à l'action au fait
d'actionner cette procédure de
licenciement économique mais n'oublions
pas quand même que l'économie c'est
aussi un rapport de force et que là dans
une période où nous a dit que c'était la
guerre quand même donc on est on est
dans une économie d'après-guerre en
quelque sorte et je crois que ce que
disaient jacky tout à l'heure sur les
formes nationales à à s'appliquer c'est
à dire que
même si la manière dont ryanair a
négocié les choses n'est vraiment pas à
la française et méritent à mon avis
d'être totalement revu il ya quand même
une question d'effort national qui va
devoir se poser puisque une crise de
toute façon c'est perdant perdant
étant donné qu baisse les salaires parce
qu'on a plus de croissance parce qu'on a
plus d'activité donc il va falloir
trouver des solutions qui contentent
tout le monde sans jamais oublier que un
effort patriotique national de cohésion
doit être menée par tous
après la guerre qu est ce qu on dit moi
je veux bien mais c'est plus souhaite
payer moins cher en font autant
si nous répond il dit un actionnaire ne
prend pas de risque lui attendre ouais
il faut que la poste donne son salaire
aux soignants puisque y en a qui ont
risqué leur vie et d'autres qui a failli
l'aide d'une boîte aux lettres avait
l'impression déjà d'être malade
ce sera pour la petite vanne non mais là
où je serais d'accord avec richard
qu'est-ce qu'il va venir et jean
reprendre l'expression du génie bastille
s'appelle le figaro où elle parlait vous
serez de ceux de ce baiser lamourette
était vraiment de se dire aller dans
cette période embrassons nous folleville
et fusion de l'union nationale pendant
cette crise
on nous a raconté des cracks sûr on va
revaloriser ceci ou cela on va faire
revenir les industries du médicament
mais effectivement il faudrait reprendre
toutes les déclarations et dire mais
pourquoi les gens ont tenu à dire toutes
ces tissus de mensonges une entreprise
peut pas se mettre à dire à alexandre ii
vecchio à charlène toi tu es bac + 12 je
vais te payer moins cher que quelqu'un
qui a échappé
moi je suis pas un homme politique je
suis pas là pour faire plaisir aux gens
mais économiquement ça ne tiendra pas la
route ou en tout cas si on dit ça
alexandre et charlène demain ils vont
dire attends là le contrat social il a
été complètement bafouée ça n'est pas
possible même si l'ombre mais il ya des
super travail
c'est quand même pas comme ça que et des
simpson et je donne un exemple
demain vous allez me vous allait
m'appeler vous allez me dire voilà on va
faire revenir une entreprise du
médicament et bien d'engager la ponction
voiture aujourd'hui
l'ouvrier chinois elle est pas avec le
ca paix et dans la question du
médicament c'est c'est avec la nature
les 2e et 3e le jeu le 10 mai mais non
mais alexandre l'industrie du médicament
quand ils compteront bafa la moi j'ai
fait des tonnes de co2 mais l'entonnoir
à l'extrême aujourd'hui elle est quand
même content quand vous allez installer
une usine de production chimique des
additifs au maître dans les dix cas mans
et que vous allez installer votre ville
vous allait m'appeler
vous allez me payer très cher parce que
tous les gens qui vont être au tour vous
mener une vie pendables parce que cette
usine de médicaments ils en voudront pas
les les batteries électriques
quand on va installer les batteries eh
bien on va enrichir les chinois parce
que tout l'écart a officié deux et qu'on
a exporté notre pollution tout ce mirage
qu'on a voulu installer en dix ans
demain on va le réinstaller enfants mais
c'est du grand n'importe quoi
ou alors on fait venir toutes ces
industries est celle et communicatrice
qui vont mais à l'enrichir parce que lui
il va y avoir des débats pendant des
mois et des mois de genre qui ne
voudront pas un lubrizol
à côté chez eux même si c'est pour
fabriquer des médicaments
moi je serais prêt à parier tous mes
futurs collègues
en tout cas tous ces mensonges là il
faudra bien un jour les expertises et
parce que trois ans ferme en abondance
ça sera beaucoup plus sain d'assumer le
prix de la pollution en réalité on fait
croire aux gens qu'il ya pas de
pollution qu'on a un modèle ça on ne
fait qu exporté effectivement la police
l'ancienne qui d'ailleurs ne se gêne pas
si on avait des unisyn de médicaments en
france je pense qu'il y aura là
certaines normes
donc ça gênerait peut-être les gens qui
habitent à côté mais ce serait quand
même dans le groupe h le week-end en
chine où il ya des villages du concert
où y'a rien qui est où on se retrouve
avec une pandémie mondiale dont il ya un
moment donné un peu de rationalité et un
peu moins de courses au trot fils ne
ferait pas de mal j'ajoute que tout ça
coûte extrêmement cher
en réalité on dit toujours les coûts
baissent pour le consommateur mais ça
coûte extrêmement cher au chômage en
dépenses sociales et moi je préfère
payer convenablement les gens à
travailler en france plutôt que choisir
des esclaves au bout du monde et faire
de l'assistance sociale dans notre pays
je crois que là il faut qu'on changera
également de paradigme sur ses six
points en jeu on remettra un jour le
débat sur la relocalisation on en a déjà
parlé c'était le titre le propos d'un
précédent épisode d' à mon avis donc
revenir un petit peu sur le sujet
aujourd'hui le temps le temps file donc
on va on va se quitter la juste quand
même la parole aux internautes
bruno qui s'indignent comment peut-on
parler à ce jour de baisser le salaire
il ya déjà beaucoup de citoyens dessous
du seuil de pauvreté et olympe qui nous
lie c'est la fée des cela fait des
décennies que le salaire des
fonctionnaires est gelé il ya un autre
il y avait une autre contribution
c'était seach qui dit un actionnaire ne
prend pas de risque lui
alors moi j'ai pas d'action particulier
mais mais mais mais et la certitude a
dit non mais surtout surtout en ont mis
c'est un fait qui est peu connu
d'ailleurs ça c'est je soumets cela aux
communicants que vous êtes
jacky mais que des actionnaires ont mis
de l'argent au pot pendant cette crise
pour pour un certain nombre pour un
certain nombre d'entreprises donc il ya
eu çà c'est une partie de la population
qui ne peut pas être actionnaires parce
qu'elle n'a pas les moyens pour devenir
actionnaires aujourd'hui un merci elle
n'est pas la chose la mieux partagée du
monde on a vu pendant cette crise aussi
qu'il ya des français des françaises qui
j'ai avec des salaires qui sont très
modestes et que même les 84 % quand ils
ont été mis en oeuvre il ne couvrait pas
100% et que ça a mis des familles en
difficulté donc on n'est pas forcément
tous actionnaires parce que parfois on
ne peut pas non plus vincent roux dans
la france d'aujourd'hui comme je voulais
dire mon cher et ça je ne le suis pas et
mais je disais c'est cette aide aux
actionnaires oui enfin ça c'est un autre
débat mais en tous les cas c'était une
info que je donnais la question qu'on
posait sur twitter justement c'était
celle là à ce qu'il faut baisser les
salaires pour sauver les emplois et vous
êtes une large majorité à répondre non à
77%
merci beaucoup d'avoir participé merci
beaucoup d'avoir participé merci d'avoir
échangé
justement à travers à travers ces débats
pardon parfois pour les problèmes de
connexion mais merci en tous les cas
particulièrement mention spéciale à
jacky et alexandre qui ont su éteindre
leur skype et le relancer pour pouvoir
avoir le débat merci beaucoup et
charlène merci beaucoup richard merci
jacky vers sélection d'avoir été présent
merci beaucoup à alban qui a relayé les
vos messages et à jean-charles cousin et
charles darche en régie avec qui ont
permis la réalisation et d'édition de
cette émission merci adrien bas j'ai
également on se retrouve demain pour le
dernier numéro d' à mon avis avant la
semaine prochaine
le retour de points de vue à très vite
sur figure live
[Musique]